tạo lăng tòa và cách nối để cục đồng có thể cùng nhau phát triển bình bướng.
Bây giờ, xí mở cửa vị chúng ta hay cùng vướng mắt lên mặt hình để cùng vinh dành các học mục giải thường
dải thường năng, nằm hành hình không chẳng hành hành dòng.
Chẳng, Wien, Education, hành trình mười năm xe chữ thấp sáng cố hội học tập bình gặng cho trẻ em bị năng
hơi hệ sinh thái bà trong hồn, liên tạo học tập số, sân trời sĩ thức và chính trị cục đồng.
Chẳng Wien đã đồng hành cùng thàm hình trị học sinh, kết nối mùi ngàn trình học, tư trắng bên tinh phịp, đến trọng bên toán,
bởi ai ai cá hình hoa, dự án thua hệ khoảng gắt công nghệ giữ hành thị và nước thôn,
bởi mỗi đứa trẻ dù ở vùng đức mào, điều sính tã hương vân gào vàng chính trị cục mình.
Ê trên át trường học, bước tập loại thung nghiệp phính thông hôn đổi việc trào, kẻ hứa tình sẽ cấp quan,
mở đồng tư lai cho trẻ em bị ngà, tướng tới một chăm phần trăm cơ sở giáo dục được kết nổ hình.
Hăng nghiên đến trường được thấp sáng các hoàn bốn hợp, làm gờ, giả hình còn chuyến thà hệ sinh lai giảy sổ hứt
giúp dẻ học cá nền quá, kêu quả hợp tư vị ngà, là hình sành nhiều cục gia, trường trình mở khán thử trị thích mất đảnh sau mòi lưu trẻ.
Công tìm của phần Mi ra, buồn kiến tế tụng hoàn, tử dân, tử dễ hí đã quả tay.
Tìm phòng từ hai em thuốc trong mời, Mi ra, si gìm mại lưỡi ở năm trăm lịm thù gần,
biến dế phy lìu tàn tay Wi ngôi sinh để nãy chính trăm hàm lắm nình tự nhiệm hiểu cải trị hích.
Tự nâng, tử nâng, tử nâng, phải mì bà trịu kể sang, và tích kìm hàm hiểu không đàn tự lý hứt,
mỗi tờ giữ tảy sinh, không chỉ là lời hữu bình mua trường, mất lắm mầm sang, giữa xuống từ lai cho thế mai sau.
Quý thiệt tâm, phục sự ở việc uống tất cả trong hoàn người, hơn người mầy năm nối xa tình người,
xin ra từ tâm người phục sự, vui thiệt tâm đã kiến định xuất cảnh ai thập tìm mong ý tế,
giáo dục và an sinh để nhỉ ngơi cận đất.
Huyện dạm mắt mắt mấy tư tình thành, bối hình người xấu ngạm thì đồng.
Vui ý đã trao cơ hội xống mới trong vui trụ người xân Việt Nam,
để mỗi tâm hậm thiệt tự xeo, xen ngày mập thành chíu gực bất đẹp trên khắp giáo dất, hình trẻ.
Cơ lập bộ o liên thế hệ tự giúp nhau của vộng người cao tối Việt Nam,
mặc lưỡi ím tương thắp sáng tối xa dựng dở, khi Việt Nam giá nhìn người cao tối đối xe hẹp thích từ sự khỏe,
an sinh và cố đơn.
Vô hình xong hộng người cao tối Việt Nam và hông hình an sinh hình an sinh hồ khởi xứng, bối ngạm chực cộn.
Tăng tu nhật, chăm sóc sự quay, chăm sóc tẹn nhạc, học tập sự đời và tự giúp nhau.
Hơn bốn trăm chính nghiệp xong hình thành viên từ chính nghiệp câu lập bộ,
đã để vô trở một miếng chính giang khi gọng đồng công Trung tay,
tôi ra hoàn toàn có thể sửa và đầy ý nghĩa.